lorsque vous entrez dans Val d'Or juste à côté
de la route 117 il y a deux mains
ensemble des fleurs et une croix c'est ici
que les restes d'une jeune
femme autochtone ont été trouvés jeanne puka sheesh a été
assassinée en 2003 le jour de son 20e anniversaire
cette photo a été prise  quelques heures avant
sa mort chaque année en octobre femmes et
enfants viennent ici pour se souvenir ils sont
aussi là pour se souvenir Cindy Rupert house
une femme algonquine de 44 ans qui n'a
pas été revue depuis le printemps 2014
un autre des disparus parmi les nombreux
disparus  au Canada,
notre enquête a commencé avec cette
disparition, une affaire qui n'a jamais fait la
une des journaux et s'estompait lentement de la
mémoire, alors que lorsque nous sommes allés rencontrer
Cindy Rupert, les parents de maisons qu'ils se
sentaient seuls et oubliés,
puis les problèmes politiques de pollution
nomment la police, ce n'est même pas le cas  même une
première visite au Kosovo à val-d'or
nous avons aussi entendu des histoires très troublantes
de femmes autochtones le dernier
téléphone de Femina la ilaha polypose mafieux
pour la première fois  le temps que ces femmes prennent la parole
elles dénoncent publiquement le mépris
qu'elles subissent de la part de ceux qui sont censés
les protéger
par plus que la pirogue installée comme un
philosophe et économiste TVM sans de
telles personnes - et la police mademoiselle savez vous
qui a porté la photographie baiser
exposé peur  et la méfiance à l'égard de la police
font partie du quotidien de ces
femmes La réponse des adjoints cliniques de Siebel
est une politique amicale
Je n'ai généralement pas le temps de faire la fête des décisions un
million Netaji
la fertilité de la ville Sydney nous sommes convaincus
qu'elle a été faite garçon Emily nous montre des photos
de ses enfants
Cindy  en queue de cheval à cheval
tous ensemble en famille
rien n'indique qu'un jour la jeune
Cindy rejoindrait les rangs de toutes les
femmes autochtones disparues au
Canada ses parents Johnny et Emily ont
parcouru sans escale des milliers de
kilomètres du nord jusqu'à  le Sud
essayant de la trouver Davy Davy
cette efficacité
devant moi en tant qu'adulte se déroule pour
Cindy Rupert maison alcool drogues
pr  ostitution et violences conjugales
malgré tout elle est toujours restée en
contact avec sa famille
téléphone je veux dire monté le groupe
salle de classe horrible Gigi non c'est une mauvaise
personne être une dame
Gigi pas en dessous elle n'est pas là pour
apparemment un parasol Gigi énergie Twitter
un peuple parle  moi beaucoup un monopole des semaines
passées puis l'été sans que la famille
s'inquiète vraiment beaucoup mais au
début de l'automne ses parents ont
appris que cindy n'avait pas été vue
depuis avril ce détachement de Québec mis à jour
en amis a commencé à enquêter
mais l'affaire a été rapidement transférée à
hyène Honda alors  au Bureau des
enquêteurs à leur quartier général à
Montréal lorsque nous sommes allés voir la famille en
avril dernier ils étaient sans
nouvelles des enquêteurs depuis plusieurs
mois
face au silence de la police Emily
et Johnny ont décidé d'enquêter
eux-mêmes ils ont imprimé 250 photos de
leur  fille et les a distribués au
Québec et en Ontario soit un peu sur
un échantillon d'une centaine de kilomètres  res
au nord de Pico Gann où
vit la famille de Cindy est le camp familial la famille s'est
réunie ici pour trouver un certain réconfort
dans la nature aujourd'hui c'est la fête des mères souvenez-vous de
lui est apparu - email 7 Facebook
s'accélère bien mais peu importe son dernier message sur
Facebook était en février  13e 2014
deux mois avant sa disparition quand un
an plus tard en janvier 2015 ce message
d'une amie
où es-tu Cindy un autre fait qui
ajoute au mystère de sa disparition
Cindy Rupert house venait de recevoir un
chèque de 13 mille dollars de la
Régie de l'assurance automobile du Québec après  ayant
eu un accident de voiture le chèque n'avait jamais
été encaissé
Cindy Rupert la maison avait une très forte
personnalité elle était agressive quand elle
était ivre et ne passait pas inaperçue dans
le centre de Val d'Or Vic Mizzy voir
voir Davi j'ai tapé dans la balle  tue cette Ivy
je suis ce que c'est ce que les boules de gâteau sont
attachées femme la dernière fois que
la maison de Cindy Rupert a été vue, c'était le 23 avril
2014,
elle est allée aux urgences du
L'hôpital de Val d'Or avec trois côtes cassées
elle a refusé de porter plainte contre son
agresseur toutes les personnes à qui nous avons parlé
étaient unanimes le
partenaire des maisons Cindy Rupert était un
homme violent mes clients un dollar be
la maison Kathy Rupert avait vu les
vêtements de sa sœur tous coupés  en morceaux,
elle m'a laissé jouer des cassettes OD bras comme je l'ai
dit je veux dire j'ai dit d'accord écoutez l'olafemi de
pondan monter l'avion moi-même de la
plaque alors j'ai dit que je les aime moolah père
muhammad firdaus sandra Levesque a travaillé
pour une organisation qui aide les victimes
d'agression sexuelle en  Val d'Or Cindy
Rupert house y est allé de temps en temps
neva mon collègue comme un député
bombardé sur une offensive c'est enfin quelqu'un se
moque de la grève c'est normal
pas si cool
nous sommes allés chercher du linge de prélèvement Cindy
Rupert house dernier partenaire nous l'avons finalement
trouvé ici alors suicidalité  nous avons
enregistré notre rencontre à son insu
merci
c'est comme ça que les gens sont duveteux maintenant pour
cet exemple je vais vous le bureau vient d'
acheter le népal népalais seama  nship le dire
parfois je Mostafavi certains vous savez même
si je ne donne pas son Ella Kim voit oh si
Jane vous mr.  moi regarde t'as pas
compris c'est tout quelques jours après
on ket était à Val d'Or ce Delta à
Québec a exécuté un mandat de perquisition au
niveau des entités appartement
un an après la disparition de la maison de Cindy Rupert
en octobre 2014 quelques mois après que Cindy a
renvoyé la maison  disparu Carolyn
chichay croit l'avoir vue dans un
grand magasin elle ne savait pas que
Cindy manquait c'est génial l'
étalon blanc Allen a gagné quelques jours
plus tard Carolyn a eu une réunion dans un centre
pour femmes qu'elle mentionne à l'un des
travailleurs qu'elle avait vu Cindy
Maison de Rupert c'est à ce moment-là que Carolyn découvre que
Cindy a disparu. Le travailleur qui a été très
surpris a immédiatement appelé la police.
J'avais l'habitude de me chercher pour ma neige.
excusez-moi Dixie
la femme de malléabilité de la première période
vous devrez déclarer cette assemblée Je
pensais qu'un homme Kay Lichtman directeur de la ville
changeait leur Amérique encore ek J'ai vu
Julie ne l'a jamais mis évolué  euh avez-vous
cette mise à jour à Québec n'est pas allé au
magasin à la
place ils ont demandé au propriétaire de vérifier
les vidéos pour choisir quelques images et de les
montrer à Carol dans le chat ciboulette c'est
ce que le propriétaire nous a dit mais il a refusé d'
être interviewé lui aussi  a dit que pour lui
toutes les femmes autochtones se ressemblaient les
images qu'il avait choisi de montrer Carolyn
ne correspondaient à aucune des descriptions qu'elle
avait données à Oconee pour moi
pas toutes séparées tu sais pas
confirmer a attaqué ce genre d'
acteur intime pas une personne compétente Sarah
des maux de tête constants dans un seul coin,
elle a dit que la portée de la famille hop appelez une
pupusa ici
la première Monica du Népal toujours assise
blonde patinée Sperry a subi un petit
traumatisme eh bien, elle Raju éloigne l'homme
juste une blonde oh il s'est battu pour qu'elle
latina qu'une police écailleuse  c'est tellement de
gaufres ballet le Cindy c'est facile
ils l'ont tous connu de la rue comme
Cindy Rupert house ils ont tous vécu avec
violence alcoolisme et moments de
grande vulnérabilité puis la discussion a
pris un  tournure inattendue
ils ont tous commencé à dénoncer publiquement pour la
première fois le comportement de
certains policiers
Charlène marionnette II a parlé de sa
sœur qui avait été emmenée la nuit très
loin du centre ville une
pratique douteuse
pour dégriser les femmes ivres  en rentrant
en ville à pied une pratique qui les rend
encore plus vulnérables
toujours fertiles multiples un policier oppa
si un Pickler qui fuit faisait bouillir quoi - il vit
au fil du temps j'ai acheté un PA
une politique prise quand est l'estomac aussi
mettre la politique dites-moi pourquoi vous  les gens
c'est impossible pour mon sabe tu es
tellement sale Whoopi une promenade de plusieurs
kilomètres puis des histoires plus personnelles
sont sorties Marta clairement le bâtard
gémit ah encore ils n'ont pas d'importance
ça m'aide par mes poches sont
domestiquement avec l'île pourtant ebdb j'ai
un  promotion Je suis un bateau à vapeur mafieux
principalement casher domestique avec beaucoup d'
insulaire en soi ma chatte est Tom Barrett
heureux du mystère lash a abandonné
un zoo confetti plus  cette délicieuse
fête, la
police utiliserait ces endroits isolés
Priscilla petit nous a emmenés à l'extérieur
de la ville, vous voyez maintenant, je pousse les hommes souhaitant peut-être
topeka Vida kamiya-san souhaite que Mandy
ressente ce qui diffère sur la police si
l'église réussissait à descendre cette échelle
d'accord encore un peuple fait peur le poisson est
faisan ne plaignez pas fossa
si j'étais le correctif South Network pour
prendre les gens de la mode publique ne
sélectionnez pas cette première paire complice la
première dame Triano sara.deluca
Bianca Bhushan connaît cette route forestière
et beaucoup  d'autres endroits à la rareté
nous montre dans une réponse similaire Lolo les meilleures
pâtes sont littéralement des politiques le défunt
désactiver le nouveau colon ce whopper
Paula bullsháá P le maréchal du
Mossad supposerait que je sois bien-aimé
il y a Lima de retour ici plus un parallèle j'ai
promis Imam nouvelle police d'affiches mon  maman
ne connaît pas la ville Warren Commission
ouais basilicum demande une myrtille a
fouillé notre laboratoire encore
Volodia Nevada politique hakufu linéarité
Savalas a nommé une Inde la plus ve  ry
moderne une note une note LeBaron Alida
schmidt baby-sitter pas d'attention Bob
seul bien sûr madame populaire elle l'aimait a
exigé la fellation au feu
c'est la sénescence
Bianca nous a ensuite emmenés à l'affût un
endroit déserté la nuit
deux fois Casa de Rosa a commencé quand elle
est allée à l'est thermostat almansi  peut voir
certaines installations dépasser un pied le
plus frais d'humidité une grande table ouverte
adopter un tel SAP accepté de façon spectaculaire
chaussettes elvis tomate aujourd'hui
afin que je puisse faire un peu de PS depuis notre école jusqu'à
tout le sauvetage s'il vous plaît ne me laissez pas
vous rappeler si je  'm payin coke défini par
Emerson les premières femmes dirigées à qui nous avons parlé
et qui ont préféré rester anonymes
nous ont raconté des expériences similaires d'abus l'une
d'elles a voulu raconter son histoire par
écrit ils m'ont fait ils m'ont sorti
de la voiture et ont tiré mon  pantalon baissé dans
le processus et m'a humilié
j'espère que quelqu'un fera quelque chose à
leur sujet parce que ce n'est pas juste
ntre
Angela King a hésité longtemps avant
de nous parler la peur est toujours très présente
cela pourrait lui donner une avance il a la
semaine aussi donc c'était une erreur mon
cousin épluche le bout des débris tu n'as jamais
connu l'autre ma politique notre
DVD ATP  dans le Nobel Europe vous dans
le dos dans notre magasin il y a une poche sur le
bas pour propager une critique si lourde de la mauvaise
figure poster la police apparemment
le premier parti mieux plus tard hajima
et ensuite supposer que la police le motel
modestement plus twinsanity va tellement
moi-même  c'était une lettre
P imaginez-vous c'est un P platine
vous savez cet Angelo peeps monsieur vient voir
Clara vient Oh voir rapide facile rapide
supposons qu'un travail de maintenance n'est jamais
payé à 7h00 pas de support pour Tata
doucement Davis v Mississippi suppo
probablement ad esquive  ceux qui font du dojo en
fait il ne sera pas que nous aurions mmm l'
épaule alors il continue à continuer d'
amniotique Apollo l'opus humide la
police se rapproche facilement d'une série je
veux dire comme j'ai celui-ci
nous ne sommes pas des enfants je  je suis  et puis travaille la plupart de
ce que dit la police
le Manoir un bar populaire à valdore qui
s'adresse aux autochtones en fait le
seul bar qui les accueille ouvertement Carol
Marcil est la barmaid ici elle est un peu
la reine des abeilles elle a entendu les
secrets de ses clients et elle en a été témoin  un
comportement brutal de la part de la police tour de Les femmes autochtones
confuses viennent rapidement à capuche en écume de mer elles
voient le poste téléphonique essentiellement quand vous
voyez la maman Gaga je magasinerais même un
étranger banal disponible application sûre aqua
deuxième téléphone pour les gars que vous connaissez le
travail bleu sur Kaiba bleu de qualité  travail voir
téléphone sac à main oh il est petit il est pour moi
tu quittes le club PDD bleu pour
le bon point le cambrioleur Dan a trouvé
cette idée suppose informatique télé non
Kane est très amusant moment aujourd'hui mr.  C ouais un
niveau de violence qui la préoccupe
beaucoup voir ça c'est viola Krishna : lol j'ai l'
impression d'avoir perdu un tu vois Babu en dessous voici
les blessures de la jeune femme que nous avons rencontrée
au Manoir elle nous a raconté comment un
policier de Val  d'Or l'a maltraitée après
qu'elle soit montée dans une voiture avec lui elle ne
voulait pas être identifiée mais elle a écrit
ce qui s'était passé il m'a jeté dehors
j'étais en route pour l'orphelin je voulais faire pipi
il voulait une pipe j'ai dit non m'a jeté
out attrapé mes cheveux m'a laissé seul sur l'
autoroute
j'ai trouvé un minou sur un financement uniforme
pour mon lock on you kiss kiss et je
vais faire ce que je vois vraiment mais c'est aussi le
voyage les populations les plus importantes
viennent s'agenouiller ou s'asseoir je te vois  sachez
Carol Marcil a hésité longtemps
avant de nous parler ouvertement elle insiste
pas tous les policiers sont comme ça
Zuzu's papad le sujet en fixe de quel côté
le calme on a mis six pour spécificité g18
sauf bas Saramago bleu Edith Cloutier
a été la directrice générale de Bell
L'ami natif de Dora  navire Centre
depuis 26 ans, elle connaît la détresse
des femmes autochtones, elle a été époustouflée par
tout ce qu'elle a entendu ici
possible Anika n'est pas une soignante ici
Oh Tandy Mahjong bientôt cesser aussi vite que
vous avez al dajjal mauvais départs à
Winnipeg
mon journal  n'apparaissez pas ma
mère s'appelle sedessa sedessa sedessa
lyrisme déposer des accusations
contre la police surmonter sa peur est un énorme
défi pour une femme autochtone certains l'
ont fait mais ces plaintes sont tombées
dans l'oreille d'un sourd on soutient un plaignant
déposez-vous une plainte déontologique Isha pousse le
Muppet  en Pologne Oh mrs.  gooje cash 10
min al choisissez vos avions de poche et la
Russie signalez un avion votre solution le
parti Mercia prévoit de me facturer un
échec des bords au sommet du shopping
Las Olas ou six poètes romains Nobel
programmés match et sur différents
ozawa voir Sally Turko non  les scrupules à
Falmouth Achtung donnent cela semblait un peu
louche un peu Co les dépôts légaux que nous avons
faits ne doivent pas collectifs la famille s'est
embrassée à tour de rôle mo croit
ekitoku Hajj le nouveau les compétences Karaka
sur moi zip silicium RK lâche j'ai vu Lucas
Sikkim semble qu'il n'est toujours pas mon
des épisodes d'horaire perso je parle
d'un petit truc un autre
est devenu un Jimmy mais je suis tout à côté de l'épidémie
j'étais
ouais
salut une chanson d'anniversaire
comme toutes les femmes qu'on a rencontrées Cindy Rupert
house a aussi traîné au Manoir voir
le renversement du sort Ramone soprano  Marc
et Vickie kita pour vous dire bien mec quoi
mais non je mentionne que les attaquants vont
paralyser l'état d'esprit l'imposer c'est
presque heureusement l'affaire politique mais
donc ils bombardent  le seau, nous rencontrons la
bruine, vous voulez dire l'écraser et une fois que je peux
courir le bandage de chaussures, cela commence normalement
être quelqu'un avec tout le dos un
budget est une
bouteille dit Priscilla Starwood l'ancienne
Priscilla uppity est à Montréal, elle a
une réunion comme envasée au
siège social de Québec  nous sommes le 22 mai
dix jours seulement après notre entretien au
Centre d'Amitié natif qui
évitera une piste à enregistrer au sujet de mme.  Casey
le pouvoir de baiser celui
qui a fait ça où est ton père,
la SQ fait le suivi de sa plainte éthique il y a
deux ans l'
incident chez Walmart - quand le Père Noël
arrive, tu as enterré ses croyances à mon sujet et
tout emportera avec eux un avenir,
elle  a également décidé de déposer une plainte
pour une agression sexuelle survenue
il y a 10 ans, celle-ci impliquant un
policier à la retraite, nous avons attendu Priscilla
devant le siège de la police, leur passé
est un silence spastique, tous les coups de poing dans la
langue emoji sont venus de Hakata kakapo
avec quelque chose de plus 3d  police
en nombre protégé cette année ça a été
amendé ethnie du québec a contacté
brasilia cinq mois plus tard en octobre
deux fois elle a annulé ses rendez-vous avec
eux à la dernière minute on l'a rencontrée
à valdore soudan abadi chatte qui
excuse autrement le poly
le plomb pousse delhi  persécuté
me voir dans son
Palooza c'est Rashad no booboo Solana embrasse
bien spassky crois-le alors quelqu'un peut-il
voir sa soeur s  des urprises l'attendent comme oh j'étais
un enfant évoluant la protéger comme oh mon Dieu
quel pasteur elle sait qu'il garde la
pétition à zéro nous avons augmenté la
confession des poulets transkei le 8 octobre
sur certains viennent monsieur la police de l'établissement est
complètement déchirée ouais
seuls les gens fils ma conscience  le
système régnant
la mère de brasilia a toujours été là
pour sa fille elle est aussi inquiète
pointilleuse qu'est-ce qu'elle ressentait à
table quand sa fille et les autres
femmes nous ont parlé des abus qu'elles avaient
vécus qui sont des juifs je porterai une
couleur unie  picki bien quitter Cepeda
Kelly le sentir les résoudre j'ai dit donc nous
résolvons vraiment aimer ma chaussette est même
partiellement supprimer personnellement parfois
Collison busking sur Paco a une personne
vraiment améliorer c'est allons-y
Johnny et Emily Cindy Rupert maisons les
parents sont à Montréal pour participer
en marche pour commémorer
les femmes autochtones disparues et assassinées, le
Québec ensablé a relancé son enquête
sur la disparition de Cindy Rupert
h  ouse quelques jours seulement après avoir découvert que
nous envisagions également la question, les
enquêteurs se sont rendus chez ses parents
pour la première fois en juin dernier, neuf mois
après avoir signalé sa
disparition,
le pauvre enfant homme qui serait totalement t
st music man neva opérette c'est comme sur
un tank Alanis téléphone oh non Chris Federer
dit que l'agenda national
veut orienter rapidement que je ne vois pas souvent
comme un visage mou ji-sun gratuit
discuter de ce que la vraie facture de la méta n'est
pas un gros problème à moins que vous ne soyez heureux
aujourd'hui Johnny et  Emily n'est pas seule,
elle est entourée de gens qui l'
encouragent et réclament une
enquête nationale sur les femmes autochtones assassinées et disparues.
Cela fait 18
mois qu'elles n'ont pas entendu parler de leur fille.
La foule leur donne l'énergie de continuer.
Samaras la marionnette  répondeur pas tout
bébé
tovahleh skittery humidité profonde Johnny
veut que je reprenne
laisse-moi toucher également le
persistant dans le fugitif sur le [ __ ] et
le possesseur mais non merci au
pr  operly le Prosecco VA de la ville a déclaré que
le médecin dansait tellement fantaisie
Masuka sur la tomate du personnel
Aviva - Roy ce gars est la politique de Harry
- maladroit a pris des affaires ohand Avendano
devant la police Varga c'est un
beau médecin et est une
deuxième coalition de politique publique très similaire  attendez
donc la prof de Québec a été mis au courant de
certaines allégations d'abus le lendemain
de notre rencontre avec ces femmes à
val-d'or après cette rencontre d'autres femmes se sont
senties obligées de rencontrer les
enquêteurs
gatos Lucie Comté se disputent la
délégation valences homme toxicomane
important
le  nouvelle politique sur le débit de ce
qu'ils font le ce qu'il ne fait pas le lectorat
certaine personne efficace ne lui donne pas
une sécurité totale dans notre pays peut-être mettre
rien met cela convertira les
symptômes efficacité c'est une politique
buku les phrases prononcées s'arrêteront et
viendront si loin  plus de temps de conversation parce que je n'ai
pas discuté ed venir exposer des impulsions vers le bas
sacrément après l'accident de Selim est un consensus
sur le rayon sur son a  ccuseurs sur les
sondages sur Toledo soeur aussi bientôt aussi
j'ai pensé que c'était la perception menée pas
oui la manière d'unité avec les émissions
huit policiers sur environ 50 en
service à valdore après que ce rapport ait été
diffusé tous les officiers ont été retirés
du service actif
parmi ces allégations, deux cas
d'abus sexuels, nous savons que l'une
des victimes est Priscilla Appétit
au moment de cette interview, le
sultan va bien Beck attendait toujours
qu'elle se présente Manolos lamantins et
Ibaka de retour sur perdu peut arrêter la nourriture saine
Emma et ainsi de suite  les gens dans songket sont
c'est comme quelque chose de non professionnel le
département des normes professionnelles est
un sous-jour de la
police des affaires internes qui enquête sur la police du péché de la
police sur le coton supposé eval da7 suis-je
en n'ai pas guidé expérimenté
deux jours après l'entretien avec la SQ
priscilly j'ai trouvé  le courage d'
identifier l'un de ses agresseurs celui
de l'incident à l'extérieur du Walmart
Sofitel de leur communauté souffle la
série  s
non-stop nous avons baisé sur
un moyen facile prédéterminé embêtant shivram a parle avec mon
charme me vilipende musica meseta oublier de
voir alexavic libéré quoi réservé Kiska
devrait être couperet n'a pas dit à Marty le type
de bouillie était malade dans mon garage je m'ai
attrapé un  le patineur avait affirmé comparer ils
représentent la police
puisque c'est rouge nous avons fini par juger le
solfège le Québec dit avoir réagi très
rapidement à la situation mais n'est pas au
courant de certains des comportements de leurs agents
la famille est tombée comme neige au
procéder sur chaque homme Felicity le  coup
de console quand le Père Noël mesurera une
sucette d'accord avec nittany quelques échantillons
et je suppose que vous ne faites pas 17 pour moi
Lee politique pas de nouveau sur c'est un poco
ha c'est ABC CLO a l'air important et il
verra des élégance  ou confirmation d'un
ski Beck agressé physiquement même pas
poxocov demain on a aussi parlé
du fait que la SQ a relancé son
enquête sur la disparition des maisons de Cindy Rupert
juste après qu'on ait
commencé à enquêter à val-  d'or et que les
enquêteurs ont contacté les parents de
la maison de Cindy Rupert après neuf mois de
silence un poème un poème dit monsieur l'amour FZ sur
d v le manquer si Don Carlos casino Susan a
dit dix note sur Super Maman pas de
psychopathes si ce n'est pas lizica tapas
aide au transit  ou l'assistance a un certain
effet sur l'apôtre séduit par le secret même
des compétences de trafic d'Atherton n'étaient
même pas dans la vallée du ventilateur Otterton, nous voyons
les spécifications sur dr.  Paul sots Québec rapporte des
refroidisseurs d'accord Lucy Ricardo George
c'était une famille de fils mais des doutes persistent et
ces histoires laissent de sérieuses cicatrices parmi
les communautés autochtones un
meilleur jus est évalué pour plus de Santosh
whoopee whoopee profond trop effrayant venez
pour venir les gars ici elle vient l'
électricité semble pauvre  Costanzo sur
la poche de fichier principal de Kevin de mon nom sur PO
suppose que je sais aider après avoir quitté l'
échange d'annonces ou les notes veulent que le soutien catalytique de Monica
Aziza du médecin connaisse son
courage à l'examen, mais ce qu'on appelle un
tournant dramatique
arrive bientôt et ce sont les
entreprises Pasco  agrafez une partie de ce tour dans la
crème solaire attendez excusez ce que encore voir à
propos de celui-là Ne
faites pas un double chiffre
vous